you talk about one of the final
engagements
that um harry and megan had one of their
final formal engagements and um
it was a moment in the state room and
you said megan began to cry
and that she said she can't believe this
is it and you also talked about a moment
in march of this year where she hugged
you
and she said to you it didn't have to be
this way
what did you take from that statement
because there could be so much meaning
in those words it didn't have to be this
way i think that final engagement at
buckingham palace not only was a
poignant moment this was a
member of the royal family taking their
sort of last steps as a working royal
uh in a palace setting for me as a royal
correspondent was surreal
but i think to see megan so emotional in
that moment and so vulnerable
just showed how far she felt that she
had been pushed
at that point the couple had really done
everything they could to make it work
as we know at the start of the year they
presented that road map to
what we've referred to as a half in half
out working model and
the fact that that was rejected and they
were forced into this position of
stepping away
that is what didn't have to be this way
and i think that's what the couple
really found difficult to come to terms
with as they headed off back to canada
that their family hadn't seen the
grievances that they brought to the
table
or try to be flexible in any way
whatsoever
as is often the case in the royal family
duty comes first
and in that instance that what they
proposed just wasn't going to work
for the institution of the monarchy the
decision that
i have made for my wife and i to step
back
is not one i made lightly do you feel
like if harry
wouldn't have married megan that he
would still be a part of
the firm and never would have left i
think whoever harry married would have
been
that gateway to exploring a different
kind of life to
challenge the work settings around him
harry someone that i think has always
needed a teammate to really complete the
picture
um i think sometimes being on royal
engagements with him when he was working
by himself
i always felt that he would really
benefit from someone by himself he would
say
so much more and i think in some ways
we've seen him emboldened
uh by his relationship with megan she's
given him confidence or at least that
relationship
and being a father has given him
confidence to speak out and be more
vocal about things
in a way that he hadn't before i would
argue that if harry had said to megan
let's stick it out for another five
years
that she would have really gone for that
because as we heard from the sources
speaking in the book she gave up
everything she was willing to give her
life to it and
the way it ended so quickly i do not
think was what she had in mind
yeah well i guess and also thank you for
asking because not many people have
asked if i'm okay
but it's
it's a very real thing to be going
through behind the scenes
do you think she her mind just didn't
really grasp it or is she too much of an
individual
to ever just be able to do it i think
there's a difference between being
warned before marrying someone like
prince harry that your life will change
for good that the press
will not leave you alone and to be
reminded of what diana went through
but particularly during those very
difficult times after her divorce with
prince charles
and these are things that megan would
have gone into that marriage knowing
but it's very different to know it than
to live it and i think whilst we saw
megan
put on a very brave front publicly as
the book tells behind the scenes she
really struggled with some of those
intrusions and just to have so many
people involved in her life
we're a fantastic team we know we are do
you feel like that harry and megan have
any responsibility in this
at all it can't just be the everything
that they did is right and everything
that everybody else did
is wrong i think really where it fell
apart is the fact that harry and megan
did want to do things differently that
they did want to
restructure the way that they worked
within the institution but
you have to remember this is a firm that
has been around for a very long time and
things work very well the way they do
you can't just
go in and try and change things and
expect everyone to agree with you
and i think that there are times like
that where we saw harry and megan arrive
in the uk at the start of the year with
this road map of how they wanted to work
moving forward i know that for other
members of the family
they felt their noses slightly put out
of joints at that time because
as one aide said to me it was like they
just arrived and handed in a rider
and said that charles was going to pick
up the bill and they were going to fly
back to
canada and get on with their new chapter
and of course it doesn't work like that
there are many layers to go through it
is an institution
there is tradition within that that has
to be respected and so
i think in some ways their eagerness to
bring change and do things differently
also got them into trouble because
that just was never going to work within
the space that they wanted to do it
you